i got electrocuted
i'm just gonna start there i got
electrocuted
and i don't know if you've ever
been down this road with electricity
uh but it's
it's a violent force man i mean it's
like
i mean it's like
like poseidon just kind of just finger
banged your butt you know that's how i
felt uh
i'm gonna tell you guys what happened
i um
i hadn't been electrocuted in a long
time
time and you forget what it's like
you forget the power of it
i was um
well first i'll tell you about the first
time i got electrocuted
i was young i was young i was a boy and
i was a young boy
and i was
i grew up near a fairground and a
fairground is a place where the fair
comes and they have animals there when
the fair isn't there and people show
animals and stuff like that 4-h people
um
and it was a big field and once a year
the fair would come and it was not far
from our
our home where we lived at
so me and some of the other boys from
the neighborhood
my friend clark
would go over there and
before the fair would open up for the
public they had a day where
they would let us ride the rides and
they charged just maybe a quarter i
think or 50 cents
and to get in
and you could ride as much
as you want as the rides were being put
up and functioning
and in hindsight i think they were kind
of just experimenting with us but we
didn't see that
we just saw it as a deal
because to get a regular wristband for
the big fair day
it was about eight dollars
and um and we didn't usually have that
money so we would go the day prior
and we'd get out there and they had a
lot of
you know miscreants and um nardu wells
out there and
you know men that were running from the
law and
women that kind of looked like lesbians
that but that probably weren't lesbians
um
non-practicing lesbians maybe
and uh and we'd get on the rides
and i got on a ride
and my buddy clark was this kind of odd
boy he had some issues
um
his
he hated sound
he hated sounds um
he hated all
just sounds man so he would often
you know wear something extra on his
head to kind of keep the sound out of
him
he just
you know i don't and i don't know why he
like he was like that um
you know everybody's got their thing and
he just
wasn't keen with sounds and
you know he liked to he was more you
whispered around him he was just a
gentle he was gentle when it came to the
airwaves
and uh and so he'd often have an extra
hat on or you know some couple of muffs
on his ears or
um he'd have his head kind of wrapped up
in something you know wrap an extra
cloth or something around his head
to keep things quiet around him
but we get onto the rides
and and it was pretty good you know i
mean someone was the first run
um you know some of the cages would have
you know birds would have nested in in
some of the
different pivots and joints of the rides
like the zipper and the tilt-a-whirl
um the gravitron
i remember the gravitron as well i'll
tell you a story about that in a second
but
so i was getting off of something i
think it might have been the
tilt-a-whirl
and
it was one of those rides where when you
get off the back
you know there's you can hear a
generator kind of really
just rumbling you can hear a generator
really rumbling
and
and i'm getting off and i i was holding
onto the rail and then i held another
rail
and at that point i completed some type
of a circuit
you know some some some sort of loose
energy
that wasn't being used by the ride
and it started using me and i remember
just like my neck got real straight and
everything i knew just felt alert
and i remember
this man was like a tall black man
and everybody was tall to me because i
was a child but
he could have been a basic heighted
basic heighted black man he was like you
got to get off the ride boy
and i was like i can't let go
you know
and he thought that i was
um
you know uh
uh taking issue with him or that i was
um you know just being kind of a
a just a little [ __ ] you know
and so he put his foot on my back and
basically just kicked me off the ride
not kicked me pushed me with his foot
and there is a difference
you know some people are always saying
they get kicked but sometimes you just
get pushed with somebody's foot
and thank god he did dude because
it was kind of rude of him but thank god
he did because i don't think that i
would have survived um
but that was i hadn't been electrocuted
since then since we'd been out there you
know experiment on these rides the
gravatron i remember they had a man in
there who looked like slash from guns
and roses
and when the when the uh that was the
one where you went in and you laid
against the wall
and then it spun
you know like you were in the dryer
and
and it spun and the whole
your the board you were leaning against
would
go just start to just levitate against
the wall
um
you know like you were really just on
the last cycle
of uh
of you know of a load of laundry and um
and at that point
you couldn't move hardly you couldn't
move your neck or anything you just had
to really look just straight forward and
they had a dj in the middle a rock and
roll man and he'd be in there playing
rock and roll and i remember this guy
was had you know had a bit of a pervert
in him and he would uh he would kind of
show his wiener while we were spinning
and it was
and it was weird because you didn't
i remember we never discussed it
because you were always
or i personally felt like i was always
unsure
if i was just spinning so fast that i
was
that i was like seeing wieners or
something that i was seeing
you know uh
adult body pieces
and and um
but now as i've gotten older i know what
happened that man was showing
was showing out and that wasn't right at
him to do that
i think he was just being like a party
guy
you know but that was the gravitron
because you couldn't move you couldn't
look and see if everybody else was
seeing the same thing
so you didn't know
if
if everybody saw it and people i guess
were maybe scared to talk about it
um
and then clark you didn't discuss things
with him that much because he liked to
be
silent you know he liked to just be kind
of by himself
but anyhow that was the first time i got
electrocuted when i was young and
and then um
until now
uh i'm okay i want to say that i had a
lot of well wishes people reaching out
you know checking in on me
somebody asked how many volts it was um
and i'm gonna answer that i don't know
bruh you know
like i don't know if that's
what you at like i'm not
i'm not like a tachometer or whatever i
don't know
i'm not trying to set a [ __ ] record
dude i got electrocuted by electricity
and i'll tell you what happened i had a
comedy set on melrose avenue in uh in
west hollywood
and
afterwards i was walking a few blocks
and they had a food truck
and i don't like food trucks man you
know it's all you know
for people out everybody in la and all
these cities are like oh food trucks
food trucks
but then they'll like
you know
but then they'll make fun of people who
are picking up animals on the side of
the road you know like the area where
i'm from and like those people are
[ __ ] up you know like some hillbilly
grilling something in the back of his
truck you know
but you're eating out of a [ __ ] truck
dude
you know like
i've never eaten sushi out of a truck
you know like some kind of damn creep
you know like some kind of just damn
[ __ ] calorie lurker you know
so i don't like food trucks because i
don't i don't like to eat
when somebody's cooking something right
next to the gasoline i mean the gasoline
in a truck is eight feet from the
[ __ ] griddle
you know like
i don't need around that [ __ ]
so anyway i've had a personal issue i
guess and um and i'm sorry if i'm a
little fired up dude i mean
i didn't i didn't expect this and it's
just been a long uh it's been a long few
days
so anyhow i saw this food truck that was
uh selling lobster lobster rolls
which
i don't give a [ __ ] about those either
dude to be honest
and so i
you know though i was being myself and i
they're they're selling lobster rolls
and i thought they were out of
jurisdiction you know i didn't know that
food trucks were allowed to operate on
this certain avenue out here in west
hollywood
so
you know being a nosy sob i wander over
because i'm thinking that these people
need to know my point of view you know
like oh you guys are selling
crab or you know seafood out of you know
out of a proper jurisdiction really
and in hindsight that was my fault i
should have minded my own business
and
kind of around the back of the food
truck they had this
you ever seen like one of those electric
things on the wall like just something
an outlet
they had a huge one of those on the
ground
and i just kind of wasn't paying
attention and um like a huge one like
like i don't know if you've ever seen a
um
like i think there's a movie maybe it
could be home alone where the boy is
dancing on a
one of those pianos that's on the floor
like with the big keys they have it at
fao schwartz they have it at a fancy toy
store in new york city
where you can step on the keys and make
the sounds
you know and they're like three thousand
dollars rich kids have them i guess
and
it was like that man it was that big it
was that big of a of an outlet you know
just a big outlet and i and had a bunch
of cables coming out and i stepped on it
and i
i i felt a me like i was
i kind of got straight and then i just
got literally crumpled to the ground
almost like if you've ever seen
like one of those videos where they pour
some type of liquid over a coke can or
something and it just crumbles
uh that was me man i was like
kind of crumbling but one of my legs was
staying kind of straight
and um
and i was scared dude it felt like the
devil was just
grabbing me down you know and i didn't
know what was going on
um and i realized that i was in unsafe
territory and thank god it just didn't
last for too long you know it's probably
two or three seconds
uh which you don't think is long you
know i mean if you're a bull rider
you know they're supposed to stay on for
eight seconds that's so
you know me riding an outlet for three
seconds isn't a big deal
but when you are unexpected unexpectedly
start
surfing electricity basically
riding the lightning
it's uh it's real man it gets real
pretty fast and so
so i was scared dude i didn't know if i
was gonna i didn't know if i was gonna
die for a second you know for one of
those seconds i probably thought that i
was gonna die um
uh anyhow i went home
um the next day
i went to the doctor and i went into the
doctor's office
and this things got even worse in there
i went into the doctor's office
and he kind of like pushed on my ribs
from the front and back and made me like
turn to the left and right
because there was this sharp pain in my
ribs
and uh
and they ended up figuring out that
there's a muscle in there that got
damaged or it's called an intercostal
muscle
and i don't know if maybe the
electricity kind of
you know
all met up right there in my body
but uh but it hurt man and this guy was
like squeezing on it made it hurt even
more
i lost my breath i thought i was gonna
die in the office i thought i was gonna
die
he pushed on it and i couldn't breathe
and he's like what's wrong and i'm like
i can't breathe
and he's like well what what
what what happened and i'm like
he had just done this to me i had been
able to breathe when i was in there
before
and i'm like i i feel like you know like
i'm gonna be killed you know
um and so he's like just take the
smallest breaths you can
anyhow fast forward i uh i slowly
breathe myself back to neutral
um
they laid me down for a while uh they
gave me a tour doll shot in my butt to
get uh some of the muscles to relax and
for a little bit of relief
and then the dude says uh don't i
suggest you don't sleep alone
you know and i'm not sleeping with
anybody right now you know i'm bedding
up by myself i don't even have a cat or
anything
so i'm thinking
well now i gotta find some [ __ ]
muppet
uh
to bed up with me you know like i i
don't want and then i'm torn because
it's like what if i get some type of
[ __ ]
you know
some straight up
[ __ ] you know just animal some female
you know just
just some girl that's out in the grind
squad i don't want some last minute
chick laying up in my bed because then
what if i what if i die what if i die in
my sleep
then everybody's like well he's [ __ ]
sleeping with this chick
um and maybe that's a silly thought i
just my brain started racing and i got
very scared um
so anyhow i've been i've been recovering
from electricity man the dude's like
find somebody to sleep with
and uh i just braved it out and slept
alone
and here i am man i got electrocuted
but i'm still alive and i'm living to
tell about it and uh and i'm happy you
guys are here for this past weekend
hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy
two
options watch one this one or this one